hello I'm Karen warden with film courage
the radio show we're here on location at
half a 50s with filmmaker nick murphy
pizza and bullets and this has been a
crowdfunding lunch today I'm curious why
are you raising money for your film well
crowdfunding is I mean I've never done
that before in anything I've ever been
I've been making phone since I was 15 my
friends and it almost close to 40 and
usually it's always been out there have
been people who donate their time and
their people who have given us some
really cool deals and vacations and
stuff and perhaps you might not but it's
all been out of pocket have never ever
crowdfunded before heading around ask
for help or investors of any kind so
what we decided to do was this approach
because I saw some since I personally
saw success through our film crew
sketches you guys and I said well you
know what if a lot of my other friends
can pull this off maybe we can too and
where are you right now for raising
funds for pizza and bullets we are as of
today we are thirty percent funded
need 70 more percent to go it's not as
if we started last week we thought oh
it's Pavillion stainless actually
started three months ago and we thought
that it would be an easier sell because
the film's them and it's nonprofit
through something called fractured atlas
is that right that is correct yeah
fractured atlas is a nonprofit
organization out of New York and the
sponsoring the arts and artistic
projects and so in order to get a proof
for that you have to apply for a fiscal
sponsorship through them and when they
approve you that you are under their
umbrella so when people donate their
donating to the arts into that
organization on behalf of warfare and so
that's what makes our filling in profit
and so that counts as a tax deduction
the tax deduction is what my producer
and I thought we would clearly have ten
thousand dollars by june three months
ago didn't I
work out that way but we're very
grateful for all the definitions that we
know so far one day the time and I
understand that you need this money in a
week and a half who saved me fully
funded when you begin shooting making
shooting in region okay down then why
it's down to the wire you know we're
doing the footwork we're doing the best
we can and that's all anybody can do you
know I'm just hoping that that somehow
miracle happens yeah I never rule out
memories so we'll see I don't want to
dissuade anyone from donating but we're
going to have to shoot a week and half
regardless of how much money we have by
then because I mean everything's locked
the crew and casts are ready to go the
locations have been deposited day four
and we have been in production for a
year and a half and worried ago we're in
this movie so it's just a matter of
getting money and got everything else we
need which is great blessing so let it
make it